[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
we're gonna find out how broke
Grandpa poopy pants is Elon Musk has
tanked Tesla
and Ben Shapiro wouldn't know what a
good movie is if he's if it sat on his
[ __ ] face good morning good Tuesday
morning it's December 27th
2022. welcome the [ __ ] back to the Tony
Michaels podcast how was your holiday oh
sorry Christmas I don't want to offend
any right Wingers out there by not
saying the word Christmas
[ __ ] [ __ ] have you okay I was out
Christmas shopping right last minute
type [ __ ] I'm that kind of person [ __ ]
you okay that's just how it rolls with
me
I was out shopping in a store looking
for a gift maybe a couple gifts I
actually picked up a couple gifts at the
store but I'm walking through the store
and I hear I overhear
some [ __ ] bonehead talking to his
daughter
now she's little right I don't know
seven six I don't know something like
that it's a little kid it's a little
[ __ ] kid
now in this store this is like a home
decor store right there's home decor
everywhere
they got [ __ ] decorations in the
entire store it looks like Christmas
[ __ ] it's pants in this store okay
everywhere it's all over the place the
[ __ ] music on the overhead thing is
Have a Holly Jolly Christmas
it's beginning to look a lot like Chris
I mean just on and on
and on
he goes on to tell her
now remember I live in rural Missouri
there's no there's no
canceling of Christmas
no one says you can't say it
it's everywhere they have [ __ ]
parades for it and Thanksgiving for
crying out loud
I mean literally from the time Halloween
ends
until you know the first week of January
there's Christmas everywhere
such boneheaded stuff this War on
Christmas
but again I observe this second hand in
a store
where the father is trying to tell the
girl
as she's walking through the store with
all the Santas and all the the Christmas
decorations the music going on their
Christmas shopping I'm sure that's what
the [ __ ] I was doing
he tries to Gaslight her and saying well
there's just I don't know what's wrong
with this country
you just won't let you say Christmas
anymore
and just you know just stupid [ __ ] like
that
I wanted to say something I really did I
really wanted to just say happy Hanukkah
right just walk up to him and say happy
Hanukkah
well you can't say that to me why are
you canceling Hanukkah there friend
are you part of cancer culture
it's really [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] this War
on Christmas
this is really dumb ass [ __ ]
I don't know if you guys experienced
this with your holiday or not that was
my one experience I stayed away from
people for the holiday to be quite
honest and really I didn't even look at
the news much
so that's why I'm talking about this
today and I'm so glad Texas Paul is on
on Tuesdays because oh man this would be
a really boring show today of me talking
about my weekend holiday but I did I
took off I didn't get on social media
much uh if if you felt ignored and my
DMs don't it's not just you it's
everyone I really tried to take a break
away from it
but I I peaked a little bit right I had
a peek a little bit I didn't know what
was going on a little bit
and this Ben Shapiro thing I couldn't
help but make this thing
the [ __ ] thumbnail and the title for
today I just couldn't help it
I don't know if you guys watched The
Glass Onion and I don't even know if you
watched Knives Out Knives Out is great
murder mystery it's hilarious it's funny
it keeps you guessing the whole time
that's the whole point of a mystery
especially a murder mystery it's the
whole [ __ ] point
now Glass Onion is has sort of the same
theme it has one of the main characters
that's in the other movie it's made by
the same people obviously
it's a good movie
it's funny
it has action in it
great script
it keeps you guessing it's the whole
[ __ ] point right of a murder mystery
and if you don't know that
well you probably don't know how to buy
lumber at a goddamn Home Depot either
and you know that the lumber doesn't go
in a [ __ ] plastic sack
little boy Lumber Ben Shapiro but here's
the thing
it's his critique of it because it has
an underlying message about climate
change that's what really pisses this
[ __ ] snowflake off that's what really
pisses him off
and it's not even really an obvious
underlying message I mean yeah they
mention it but it's kind of the theme of
who the [ __ ] guy is
but I was as I was watching the movie
and I don't mean to ruin it for you and
if I do ruin it for you well it's your
fault you didn't [ __ ] watch it yet
here's the thing
by The End by the end
the dude the guy
um the character who is the the grand
genius the billionaire
he reminds you a lot of someone else
and I don't know if that's what you know
if it was the climate change [ __ ] that
really got Ben Shapiro going or if it
was the if it was the obvious
nature of how [ __ ] ignorant most
billionaires really are one in
particular a real one not a fictional
one like in this movie but a real one
maybe that's what really pissed him the
[ __ ] off the other thing it might piss
him off
is there was you know there wasn't um
it was nudity but there was you know
some good looking actresses in the movie
some good looking dudes in the movie
obviously why wouldn't you have good
looking people I mean that's kind of the
point you want people to watch it right
maybe that's what pissed him off you
know
I don't know I mean Jesus Christ the the
song wet ass [ __ ] pisses him off
because he can't get his wife wet maybe
maybe just maybe
good looking people just pissed Ben
Shapiro off and jealous or something I
don't know
I don't know
but speaking of billionaires and maybe
Ben Shapiro that was the angle that he
was upset about this movie this um Glass
Onion and again if you haven't seen it
that's your fault I'm not gonna do the
whole I'm not gonna spoil it for you and
that kind of [ __ ] look if you haven't
watched it and you're listening to the
show man it's not my problem
the spoiler thing and don't tell me
now look
it is what it is if you haven't seen
Avatar 2 if you haven't seen violent
night if you haven't seen Babylon if you
haven't seen Glass Onion
now you need to make a little more time
for movies if you don't want it to get
spoiled I guess
but
it remind me of this billionaire
and this morning we wake up and it looks
like
to me
that Tesla
is just the shittiest [ __ ] stock out
there
and you know I I was thinking maybe it
has to do maybe it has to do with
Tesla's really are piles of [ __ ] I mean
come on if you own a [ __ ] vehicle
that spontaneously combust I don't care
if it's an EV or if it's a
1971 Chevrolet Camaro I don't care if
those cars were spontaneously combusting
no they would be known as piles of [ __ ]
have you ever heard of the Corvair
Chevrolet made a Corvair
it's a pile of [ __ ] it's garbage like
just the most horrible [ __ ] car
Chevrolet has ever made in the history
of its tenure of making vehicles and
everyone knows that the Corvair is a
pile of [ __ ] [ __ ] right it's known as
a pile of [ __ ]
Tesla is gonna be known those cars
because they just [ __ ] burn up
as big piles of [ __ ]
I don't know what else to tell you now
having said that even though these cars
may be just [ __ ] junk
and just scrap Heap right I mean maybe
the batteries are good and some of the
technology is able to be Advanced right
whatever
but I'm beginning to think
I'm beginning to think that Tesla stock
has a lot to do with its derelict CEO
who is supposed to be this world genius
who's supposed to be the inventor of
electricity or some [ __ ] you know what I
mean he takes credit for [ __ ]
everything that he doesn't do
I'm beginning to think
just just hear me out here just like
Donald Trump's presidency was absolutely
tanked by his [ __ ] Twitter account I
believe
at this point it seems as if Tesla is
tanking because of elon's Twitter
account I'm just you know I'm just
snowballing here of course it is look I
give Elon way too much credit and I know
I know Texas ball is going to want to
talk about Elon today for sure and he
may want to talk about the Ben Shapiro
thing I hope I didn't ruin the last
onion
for Texas Paul he's got to go watch it I
don't know did you watch it Texas he's
in the green room I can see him did you
did you watch grandson in Texas well he
didn't watch it I [ __ ] I'm gonna ruin it
for him [ __ ] it
it's your fault Texas Paul you didn't
watch it hey what are you gonna do you
come to the show we're gonna talk about
Glass Onion it's your fault I I don't
tell you I don't tell you I don't know
what to do about it it's just what we're
gonna do
but here's the thing about Elon
could there be
any other example
of why we need to tax the ever-loving
[ __ ] out of billionaires then the
example that we have right now because
the the idea from the right is well you
can't text the job creators
job creators really Elon Musk is a job
Creator [ __ ] spent 44 billion
dollars to lay off the entirety of
Twitter
right before the holidays the merry
Christmas crowded and pissed off about
that huh
[ __ ] out of here job Creator my ass and
then there's supposed to be brilliant
Geniuses right
because they're supposed to figure out
how to get their wealth back into the
economy with their little business that
they got in mind right the trickle-down
effect
well [ __ ] me you talk about it you talk
about
trickle down God damn I mean I don't
know exactly the dollar amount at this
very moment
that the Tesla stock has lost but it's
but it's got to be at least 75 am I
wrong it was like 113. I don't know what
it is right now it's probably going to
dip below 100 within the next few days
especially if that [ __ ] doesn't
put his iPhone down
it's got it's got to be it has to be
it has to be under one is it under 110
yet I don't know we'll check into it
but this is an epic failure this is one
of the worst performing stocks
this year
and he's supposed to be some kind of
[ __ ] genius people
now you can you know these [ __ ] these
[ __ ] Elon simps are gonna blame it on
a lot of [ __ ] other than him
I can't see exactly Texas Paul is trying
to tell me
71 oh God damn God
God sounds brilliant
I don't know about you
but if I was a billionaire
and I had this great company that I was
known for that almost all my the
entirety of my wealth was built into and
I had to sell off like 30 billion
dollars just to keep my other company
alive and the stock dropped 71 I would
think you guys would start to question
me don't you I don't know I'm just
saying and I gave Elon way too much
credit like I was saying way too much
[ __ ] credit
way too much [ __ ] credit
I really thought he was smart enough not
to buy Twitter
I really thought the dude was going to
be like all right I'm gonna pay the 16
17 million whatever it was that was
going to get him out of the deal
think about the scenario here okay think
about alternate reality since they live
in an alternate reality imagine if Elon
Musk would have just
paid to walk away from Twitter
for a minute
think about
think about all the the laughs that we
wouldn't have
because we are laughing we are laughing
but think about
the actual implications
of Elon Musk just utter [ __ ]
stupidity now I I believe that Donald
Trump is a buffoon I don't think he's
cognitively impaired and he's got
dementia I I don't believe that [ __ ]
narrative
you know I call him Grandpa poopy pants
and the reason why he may have you know
a little continence problem is because
he's been sniffing Adderall for 40
[ __ ] years okay drugs does a hell of
a job on your [ __ ] digestive system
and your bowels okay it really [ __ ] you
up
that's what the sniffling's about that's
what the breathing's about
he's been on way too many drugs for way
too long
but I don't believe he's cognitively
impaired he's delusional
he's a lunatic he's an egomaniac
but he's not he's not like losing his
[ __ ] memory he's just a buffoon okay
and he's operating on maybe a few less
brain cells I'll give you that
but Elon Musk is a Bonafide [ __ ]
idiot
I mean just about and whoever is around
him
that isn't I mean
Donald Trump was gonna be the dictator
remember he was the president of the
United States He wielded the the most
powerful office in the entire world
he had real power real absolute power in
the office of the presidency that's what
affords anyone who makes it to that
office
Elon Musk is just
some [ __ ] [ __ ] on the internet
if you re if it really boils down to it
what else does he got
what else has he done he didn't he I
mean I mean he takes credit for
everything else which
is a guy on the internet right
I mean that's kind of boils down to the
definition of a guy on the internet
takes credit for everyone else's [ __ ]
work
he's got tons of money but he really
didn't he didn't have that much money he
really wasn't the wealthiest man in the
world
that Forbes [ __ ] is all nonsense all
[ __ ] all of it
when you go read the Forbes list don't
believe a goddamn word it says and the
reason why is because their wealth is
built in this imaginary Blue Sky
right
I mean it looks like it Elon Musk
couldn't just [ __ ] out 44 billion
dollars to buy Twitter
he had to go to the Saudis and the
Russians
to loan him the [ __ ] money because no
one else would no one would take that
risk besides someone who might cut his
[ __ ] throat
he has to sell his stock from Tesla at
the worst possible time as it's tanking
and it's getting worse
just to keep Twitter alive
this guy is a bona fide [ __ ] idiot
it is almost like one of the bot trolls
in your thread
was born to a father
who who benefited their their entire
wealth on apartheid
and handed you their wealth and you
[ __ ] blew it I don't know how broke
elon's gonna get I know I know uh
because he is a bona fide idiot
this guy will go flat broke
prove to the world how smart he isn't
he will do that
no question
at all he will absolutely go flat
[ __ ] broke the proof to the world how
stupid he is
he's gonna do it
Tesla's done SpaceX will be done all his
other Ventures will be sold off Pennies
on the dollar I don't even know by the
by mid next year unless he does find
someone
who actually wants to run Twitter
because he keeps saying oh no one runs
Twitter because I'm the only one no one
wants to run that piece of [ __ ] now
you [ __ ] it up man you totally [ __ ]
it up
No One's Gonna Come Back and help you
rebuild it
No One's Gonna Come Back and help you do
Twitter 2.0 and if you do manage to get
Twitter 2.0 off the ground it's gonna be
worse than the pile of garbage that you
have now
so my guess is by sometime next year
elon's gonna [ __ ] sell that thing for
pennies on the dollar
and it's going to take years if it ever
is rebuilt
maybe Jack Dorsey buys it I don't know
he's a [ __ ] buffoon
just like Donald Trump just like Donald
Trump lost all his daddy's money
lost all his daddy's money to prove to
the world how [ __ ] stupid he is
you see how this works
do you see the writing on the wall yet
do you understand why I'm so good at
predicting it's not because I'm good at
predicting
this old story tells itself over and
over and over again just look at the
George Santos story everyone is freaking
out about this guy I want this guy to be
in Congress I want that [ __ ] to
go on the house floor and tell
Republican lies
what in the world would I not want to
politicize Republican lies from an
obvious [ __ ] liar for everyone's
getting freaked out they want him to
resign maybe the governor will appoint a
Democrat just hang on a second
just just to hang on to set one seat
ain't gonna make a hell of beans worth
difference right now
what George Santos get on the floor let
him be a media [ __ ] because that's the
only way he'll survive
and let him tell lie after Rye after
Republican lie and let them stand there
and let him tell those Lies when he is
proven proven to be a [ __ ] fraud I
mean he ran as a [ __ ] Republican
I mean isn't that fraud enough
isn't that a lie enough running as a
Republican
I'm telling you there's nothing more
beautiful right now than Donald Trump
tanking the Republican Party Elon Musk
helping them tank the right
and George Santos is gonna take office
and gonna swear himself in
an oath to the Constitution
and then he's gonna go and proceed to go
to the house floor and Kevin McCarthy is
gonna let him tell every single
Republican lie and we get to hear George
Santos tell the Republican lies into a
microphone we have it we'll have it
recorded
and we get to pin all those Republican
lies with a liar like George Santos I'm
telling you
there's no better politics than George
Santos taking office and the Republican
not punishing him one bit for his fraud
and his lies
because this is well beyond this is well
beyond the power of the presidency you
know we thought oh well the reason why
the Republicans are willing to go along
to get along with Donald Trump is
because it's the power of the presidency
no
no it's because they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
eating Liars
and they don't give a [ __ ] about anyone
else but their own God damn power
and there's no way at this point in this
Congress when Kevin McCarthy needs that
[ __ ] vote he has to have George
Santos
he will not get to 218 without that
[ __ ] he does not care what lies
he told who those allies affected he
does not give a [ __ ]
because he's a Republican and it's only
it's only about his own God damn power
they don't give a [ __ ] about you
they don't even give a [ __ ] about each
other
Kevin McCarthy will 86 George Santos as
soon as he can
but he can't right now he needs that
[ __ ] and he needs his lies and
he needs his fraud baby oh they need it
more now more than ever so guess what
make him [ __ ] own it make them
[ __ ] own it let's make them own it
I can't wait I can't wait for George
Santos to go on the floor and put on the
record that lying ass fraud
lying ass [ __ ] to put on the
record out of his mouth
the Republican lies that they tell every
single [ __ ] day
think about it in that aspect think
about it in that context think about it
in that narrative
we don't want George Santos to resign I
don't oh my God it's gonna be such great
entertainment folks till I probably
March or April until Kevin McCarthy
catches on to us about making George
Santos part of the national narrative
that Republicans are [ __ ] frauds and
they're liars and they love it oh they
[ __ ] love the LIE
they love it they love what comes with
their lies I mean look at George Santos
he's living in heaven right now
the guy couldn't be happier I mean he's
a Republican
I mean everyone knows he's now a fraud
it's out in the open
he's being talked about
Republicans love this stuff
they [ __ ] love being known to be a
fraud
they don't give a [ __ ]
you kidding me it's their dream speaking
of frauds
I would be dare looked at my duty if I
didn't mention the the first subject
that I brought up as soon as I came on
air which is Trump's tax returns we are
supposed to get
the tax returns starting to drop today
sometime midday I don't know maybe live
on the air
I have no idea now it's going to take a
few days to thumb through these things
but I'll guarantee you this there is
definitely going to be crime uncovered
for sure right right out for everyone to
see
but the thing you have to remember
is when you're when you're forming your
narrative and our messaging our national
narrative to make sure these [ __ ]
fascists do not take power and to make
sure that Donald Trump is 86 and the
trash can of History like the garbage he
is
remember the thing that bugs him the
most the thing the reason why he hid his
tax returns from us in the first place
has nothing to do with the crime that
he's committed not a goddamn thing he
thinks he's immune from any crime that
he commits if you haven't if you don't
know that you haven't been paying
attention the thing that bothers him the
[ __ ] most is that he's broke as a
joke folks [ __ ] ain't got two
nickels to squeeze together it's all
pretend it's all always been pretend
that this [ __ ] is a billionaire
that's the one thing he does not want
out in the open that's the one thing he
does not want the narrative
so when you start hearing the media
talking about crying this crime that
when the Department of Justice Jack
Smith Merrick Garland needs to resign
all this nonsense just remember one
thing
the thing that damages Trump the most is
his [ __ ] little fragile ego
and we have to attack we have to attack
it
with our national narrative and if we
can make Maga think about this if we can
make manga go on the defensive not about
the crime they don't give a [ __ ] about
the Jack Smith and the prosecutor is
going to sniff out the crime don't worry
about that
if we can make manga's total narrative
trying to prove that he's not a total
[ __ ] failure and total [ __ ] broke
and it's complete [ __ ] utter loser
that is where the Battleground is folks
that's where the Battleground is
and the thing is if we could get his
supporters to have to defend him without
us even saying anything
I mean imagine imagine you type out
something about your cat and you get I
don't know you got a Blue Wave in your
Twitter account or on your Facebook page
and someone comes and says Donald Trump
is the biggest most successful
businessman ever in the history of of
ever ever I hope
think about it you got him hand you got
them pinned that's where we want them
that is where we want them folks because
that means they're losing and we can't
we cannot give up on this fight
we cannot give up on this fight we have
to make them fight each other
we're in a Republican primary season and
I'm excited
I'm excited for the new year
2023 baby is gonna be the best year with
you the best audience in the world so
don't go anywhere we have Texas Paul
with us right after these messages
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ]
em we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
it's Tuesday
December 27th
2022 just want to put a mark in the time
it's the bottom of the first hour you
know what the hell that means
we got the minus Mighty favorite here
Texas Paul
Texas Paul how was your Christmas uh I
definitely can say that it was it was
really wonderful we uh we didn't have
but the immediate family here we dialed
it way back this year yeah and didn't do
all the crazy [ __ ] I usually have my
Lawns covered in blow ups and all that
[ __ ]
you mean blow up decorations not not
blow up dolls right right oh okay okay I
just
I'm just making sure you know we got to
get back back on track here at the
Johnny Michaels podcast
are you working on your light oh that's
beautiful yeah look at that light make
that make that cowboy hat shine so so
you had the family there did you get any
good Christmas gifts
uh you actually I got the best Christmas
gift ever yeah I got the best Christmas
gift ever
my my I love hot sauce I do I put it on
every damn thing I damn near put you
know I put hot sauce on my damn cereal
you know what I mean it's just
hot sauce on his ice cream folks my slip
my slim jim tacos everything I put it on
everything you know
[Laughter]
let me tell you something everyone
Texas Paul made me think that it it
tasted great and then I actually I tried
it on the show and I was trying to make
you know make him feel good by my um
making him think that yeah I thought it
was great and then I tried to eat it
after the show oh my God it's so [ __ ]
nasty it is the nastiest [ __ ] thing
you're such you son of a [ __ ] oh my God
if anyone wants to I don't know what
episode that was but I I Texas Paul and
me ate slim jim Tacos on yeah anyways so
that was your fault that was your fault
I did start it with the stupid damn
picture I've been following the uh the
account on Twitter I think it's called
weird food pics or some [ __ ] like that
and there's been a lot of weird ones
that I haven't sent you that I want to
do but I knew it might stir up trouble
here on the show so I didn't actually
tell us about your gift your hot sauce
oh man my my daughter my my
granddaughter actually
and my daughter did this together but it
was my granddaughter who just insisted
on it she knows me you got that one
grandkid that knows you you know this
this kid knows me man and they got me a
box they're an honorary little [ __ ]
aren't they yeah they are yeah if they
know you really well they got to be an
honoring little [ __ ] oh I tell you what
man I don't have to worry about that kid
at all she's gonna do great she ain't
gonna take [ __ ] off nobody I actually
worry about her husband because you know
she's kind of girl that would puncher
[ __ ] you know what I mean she oh okay
she yeah she's spicy but anyway she got
me this assortment of hot sauce that's
that's
perfect I mean perfect it's got mango
habanero in there it's got uh Chipotle
lime it's got I mean the original
buffalo hot sauce it's got I mean
there's a dozen of them in there man I'm
telling you that was best gift I've ever
I think I've ever gotten man I'm telling
you yeah well I can't do hot sauce and
it's not I mean and I don't like hot
food really that much spicy food
um but it's not really eating it that
bothers me so much it's um you know
trying to get rid of it is the thing
that um I can't handle whoosh you know
sometimes I feel like I'm gonna blow out
the old o-ring or something I just can't
do the hot stuff I just can't I feel it
all the way down all the way man all you
got to do just keep telling yourself
no no I'm not gonna do it not gonna do
it I'm not going to do it see and
everyone says um TMI too much
information I'm just telling you the
honest truth I know what day you want
from me I just speak the truth here on
these Tony mango podcast you know we
really should do something like a Texas
Paul Food Channel or something you
should do a food thing I'm dead serious
maybe maybe you just you just try like
these stupid videos of people trying
because I couldn't do it oh my God I'd
be dead trying like the hottest chips
and trying the hottest this and the
hottest that you should do some of that
I don't I don't I love Hot Sauce but I'm
I'm not stupid I don't do that Carolina
Reapers I don't do I don't do ghost
peppers I don't you know I want to be
able to taste pepper in it you know what
I mean I like that the flavor pep you
know pickled jalapenos are fantastic
because they're really not that hot and
you could taste the jalapenos in there
you know I mean [ __ ] like that I like
but these people you see munching down
them Carolina Reapers and [ __ ] like that
that is insanity that is could you
imagine I've never eaten any of that
because I I would die
probably I wouldn't be around that's how
[ __ ] bad it is I just I mean like
like I can do Buffalo Wings and stuff
like that but I can't really
hmm I can't do the real hot [ __ ] I just
can't I can't do it and again it's not
because of the taste it's because of the
you know the uh the experience
afterwards so yeah you know I I know I I
don't want to burn the house down uh
from the bathroom
um speaking of speaking of uh hot stuff
did you see this [ __ ] video I want to
show you this there's a video of the uh
you know what Christy gnome is is
[ __ ] idiot oh my God so apparently
her staff got her a [ __ ] flamethrower
right and this is a video of the
governor what burning what looks like I
don't know a stack of cardboard boxes
and this is her using her um her
flamethrower this is actually if I ate
Carolina Reapers like you were saying
this is probably what I would [ __ ]
feel like the next day but let's let's
watch
everything
perfect
okay as cool as this is Texas ball and
I'm gonna put this on mute we're going
to watch this for a few rounds it's cool
as a flamethrower would be like you know
I'm not I'm gonna admit it a
flamethrower would be pretty cool I'm
not good it would be pretty [ __ ] it
would but why in the [ __ ] why in the
[ __ ] do civilians need to own
flamethrowers one in the this is just as
dumb or Dumber like why can't you just
do the Good Old Farm thing and get a
[ __ ] torch okay like you you got a
torch I know you got a torch laying
around I do right you might even have a
propane um torch that you hook up to a
propane tank a lot a lot of people have
these things why in the [ __ ] do you need
a weapon that shoots fire when you
literally already have one again I mean
you know might be a little more
ineffective but why are we doing this
why the [ __ ] are we doing this stupid
[ __ ] I'll be honest with you I don't
really have a problem with that my
problem comes in is that you know that
you're gonna get some crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] that listens to all those
right-wing rhetoric you know where they
dehumanize people and [ __ ] like that and
you're gonna get some crazy [ __ ]
that's going to do something horrific
with it
you know Tony you standing out at your
place with a freaking flamethrower
melting snow on your sidewalk or
whatever you want to do Carolina Reapers
because I actually bought the
flamethrower yeah right you know either
I don't have a problem with that I
really don't you know and I live out
here where we you know what she's doing
right there I did that yesterday I did
that yesterday not with a plan
I actually improvise I improvise a
flamethrower I I take a uh and tape a uh
uh sprayer you know a pump sprayer yeah
I've I've got a backpack sprayer I fill
it with diesel yeah and then I tape tape
the wand to my leaf blower fire my leaf
blower up
get a good bit of pressure and then
fire it out once I got the fire started
and man I tell you what I can burn green
limbs I can burn anything man you know
well tell the audience why you use
diesel fuel instead of gasoline because
that's important that's Farm flashing on
the that's right well because the fumes
aren't as um as flammable and guess have
you seen the video
um I think it was a revenge video and a
revenge of someone trying to get revenge
on their boyfriend I believe and she
goes up to the car she breaks the back
window she dumps an entire what looks
like about a two gallon uh jug of
gasoline in the back seat
um and if you know anything about
gasoline like anything about fires and
gasoline you would know you do not want
to dump a two gallon jug into a
contained
um compartment like a car and let the
fumes sit for a few seconds
and then throw a match into it because
it's not exactly the gasoline that is
flammable it's the fumes that are coming
off the gasoline that are so flammable
and it's and when she does it it just
like explodes in her face and of course
she's kind of shocked but um something
makes me want the flamethrower that
Christy gnome has to malfunction when
she I don't know something in me
something in me I don't hey man you
listen when you when you [ __ ] play
with fire sometimes you get burnt that's
just how it's gonna work so
um
so you don't you don't think there's a
problem with civilians owning
flamethrowers then no I really you know
I really I really don't I mean I think
there should be limitations on it I
don't think you need an actual see
that's you know you don't need an actual
like freaking Napalm driven flamethrower
that can shoot Flames 40 freaking feet
right but you know this is the way I
talk about guns and everything we are a
big damn country we are
and not everything is the same and what
would work in a city really won't you
know won't work in the city works out in
the country it does I mean there are
places where you know I've got to burn
green brush sometimes I just don't have
you know I've I've had to think my
wife's about to kill me I've had a pile
of brush out by my front gate drying
forever and you know so it'll burn and
and and and
sometimes you don't have that
opportunity
is that your excuse or is it actually
drag I mean come on I know I know Mrs
Texas ball is watching so I just want to
hold your shoes watching it and you're
not helping me here Tony you're really
not helping me because I because I know
how it goes when you have a pile of
brush laying around bro you know you're
like ah it's been windy or you know bro
I know what I'm doing tomorrow I know
what I'm doing tomorrow now thanks bro I
appreciate it the wind's gonna pick up
here I I know Alan goes I know how it
goes
um you know I want to move on to this um
this George Santos story oh my God I
really honestly I didn't want to talk
about this much but the more I think
about it and the more uh liberals call
for him to resign I'm thinking no that's
not what we want to do you heard you
heard in the first 30 minutes as you I I
definitely want George Santos to be a
pillar and the Republican in the
Republican can party and I hope that
people understand that yes he is a fraud
and that's why he ran as a republican
number eight on Twitter right now
trending is Jewish
not Jewish okay so I I can't eat is this
is this [ __ ] real
did this guy really say this [ __ ] that
he wasn't saying I'm Jewish like like
you know descendant of Jewish people he
said Jewish kinda like I what the [ __ ]
does that mean Texas ball
what the [ __ ] it means that he's a
stupid racist [ __ ] that doesn't know
what he's talking about and you know
it's this is a win-win for us no matter
what happens here we win right I mean if
this guy stays in Congress he becomes
the face of the Republican party and
he's racist and stupid he's he's got a
the the self-awareness of a dog licking
its own ass in the middle of the street
or Marjorie Taylor green either one but
you just
can't lose here because if he resigns
then yeah the Democratic governor of New
York appoints a Democrat to a seat which
is great but
I would almost like you said like to
have him around to kick the [ __ ] out of
for the next two years until he loses
his the next election well a guy like
that's not going to be effective I mean
he's not going to be able to turn this
around he's just going to end up
bumbling I mean look at that look at
this statement Jewish I mean what a
freaking anti-semitic racist thing to
say you know well I mean he was trying
to clean I think he was trying to claim
to be Jewish at some point because you
know it was good for the room I guess
probably in other words kind of claim he
flat out said it I'm Jewish and now he
also said he was gay
oh really I didn't know this so he's is
he trying is he trying to court the woke
mob or what is he trying to do here
because those would be things that maybe
someone trying to court the woke mob
would would you know I I've got to say
um
and I can do this okay because when I
point one finger I point three back at
me like you know it you know we
Democrats here in Texas didn't really
freaking set the world on fire in the
last election the goddamn New York
Democrats
I don't know what the [ __ ] they were
thinking they could have checked he's
taking me
right he's in New York right if they'd
done one bit of Oppo research on this
guy they could have destroyed him and
picked the seat up but they didn't like
they didn't I think someone said on
Twitter who who was the Democrat running
against it was it a serial killer or
what the hell is going on um no you've
got to you've got to understand
everything he was claiming
is actually helpful if you're running as
a Democrat New York right it was I mean
he's like the work mob is what he was
going to be right yeah he's trying to be
a mother woker well here is um here's
Kevin McCarthy I guess this is a
response that's a recent response from
him about the fraud last month last
month he did it oh Okay let's listen but
I really want to talk about
who's the makeup of this new majority
you heard from some of all already
you know with Max Miller in Ohio George
Santos in New York and you had David
kustoff from Tennessee get reelected
he introduced him
do you realize we have the largest
Republican Jewish caucus in more than 24
years oh Jesus Christ now you know
what's funny about that he names
three [ __ ]
and one of them one of them's lying
about being Jewish holy [ __ ] let me tell
you something if you have never seen if
you've never seen the Republican party
in a nutshell boy you are going to see
it over the next year you oh man it is
going to be clear as day and we're gonna
point it out to you every [ __ ] day
let me tell you something I I really
thought this George Santos story at
first I was like this he's just another
[ __ ] Republican of course he lied
what the [ __ ] he's a republican of
course he [ __ ] lied but I think
there's more to this story because uh
some people are digging in to his income
on some of his uh his actual disclosures
and it looks like the guy went from
making like I don't know you know 40 or
50 Grand a year to like 700 000 now I'm
not begrudging anyone whose income goes
up that much if you have that
opportunity you know what that what
that's about what that's about uh if
I've got my facts straight and I'm still
digging on it so don't don't pin my hide
to the wall if I miss this one but what
I've seen so far is is that a guy that
that that was behind on his rent
suddenly loaned his campaign seven
hundred thousand dollars that's where
that seven thousand dollar figures
you're saying George Santos was behind
on his rent
yeah
yeah and he loaned his campaign so he
gave out of his pocket a guy who makes
50 Grand a year seven hundred thousand
dollars
yeah and now is he come from a silver
spoon household or something
do not believe so that's okay I'm still
digging on this so don't hold me don't
hold me do this this is what I'm reading
so far hmm uh no no uh I mean maybe he
would have claimed that he would have
claimed that rather it was a lie or not
he bro of course I won the lottery I won
the LA I mean he really did kind of win
the lottery to be honest with you Texas
Paul I mean he got him yeah I don't know
I don't know if if Brett Kavanaugh's
sugar daddy that paid off his credit
card debt came to see him say
[ __ ] huh yeah yeah I don't know
but suddenly a guy that that that's
that's that's blue you know Blue Collar
barely barely you know making ends meet
suddenly loans his campaign 700 Grand
and
there it is which ain't James on to me I
was about to say uh Peter Thiel I mean
you know this guy this scumbag loves to
that's where JD Vance uh came from his
old Peter Thiel so that may that may be
it I don't I don't know yeah well here's
the problem and to to if the loan came
from him personally that means he's got
to claim that 700k as income [ __ ] I bet
he spent it all he probably got the
money for the taxes on there huh I'd do
the same thing though I'd [ __ ] up the
taxes on that kind of money wouldn't you
oh man I'd go crazy someone give me
something it ain't never worth it
not earned money not earned money yeah
I'm talking about you know giving money
um no a lot of things
Public Service Announcement there are
enough to do if you run into a big load
of money get a tax lawyer there is
enough deductions out there that you
will not get hurt not like mine not
cheat on your taxes okay
there's apparently a huge jackpot now
I'm not a lottery player but is it the
Mega Millions it's like
570 million or some [ __ ] so I think it's
a lot it's ever been this time of year I
believe
I don't spend a lot of time not really
no I don't know I've never really
gambled much in general I've always
worked too hard for my [ __ ] money to
piss it away but you know maybe
the whole point of a casino is it's
stacked in their favor and
you know the longer you play the more
assured you are you're gonna so I every
once in a while I'll take a couple
hundred bucks and me and the wife go to
a casino for fun and yeah it's more to
hit more to hit the crab buffet than it
is the casino but but uh you put hot
sauce on your crab too oh yeah but yeah
oh yeah you take that butter the melted
butter put a little hot sauce in there
um here is uh everyone's been comparing
George Santos and this is a great
speaking of movies uh earlier Catch Me
If You Can it's a great movie I'm sure
Ben Shapiro doesn't like it though
there's too many brokers in it or some
[ __ ] but George Santos really does Catch
Me If You Can like it the lies keep
coming right it keeps coming and coming
and coming and coming
speaking of someone who can't make his
wife come and who hates movies have you
seen this about Ben Shapiro
have you seen this where he's talking
about this [ __ ] movie Glass Onion now
you haven't seen a movie
I've got to tell you Ben Shapiro Ted
Cruz is that the other you know [ __ ]
Harvard you know [ __ ] Harvard I mean
that has to be you're talking about you
talk about the greatest Fall From Grace
you know as an 80s kid that's what
everybody wanted was to go to Harvard
you know it was supposed to be some
mystical place where you could Infuse
yourself with knowledge and ability and
this that the other [ __ ] Harvard I mean
Jesus Christ yeah and and he's talking
[ __ ] about Rihanna I'm gonna pronounce
it wrong Rhian Johnson who I loved
Looper I saw Looper and I didn't get to
see knives out yet I used to go to
movies all day and watch the movie
Knives Out not yet okay watch knives out
and then you gotta watch glasses watch
them in that order
um I was looking at I I like rotten
tomatoes I do because I used to go to
movies every damn movie that came out
man I was a movie Nut I saw a Pulp
Fiction 22 times
22 times I saw Pulp Fiction
tomatoes on on Glass Onion here 93 man
audience score that's rocking it right
there and then you got Ben frickin
Shapiro whining like a it's and you know
what it is is these right Wingers have
to be told what to be mad at
oh absolutely well that's what he's
trying to do because you got to remember
Ben Shapiro and daily wire drives a lot
of their National narrative it's why you
get this drag show [ __ ] they're the ones
pimping this drag show [ __ ] over at the
daily wire trying to stoke hate towards
lgbtq Community right because they want
stochastic terrorism they want people to
go you know take down power grids and
terrorize hospitals and terrorize
children terrorize other human beings
shoot up [ __ ] nightclubs that's what
they want that's what the [ __ ] they want
it's what they want so they'll find
anything and of course this movie and
I'm gonna ruin it for you but this movie
has an underlining tone of climate
change the billionaire this the genius
billionaire in the movie which he turns
out not to be a [ __ ] genius he's a
dumb [ __ ] which again the parallel to
the current billionaire dumb buck that
is absolutely destroying Twitter is is
[ __ ] amazing it actually is amazing
they made this movie long before they
knew Elon was gonna buy Twitter and it
is amazing the pair loss but anyways the
point is is that in the movie they're
trying he comes up with
science right a product that is going to
create clean energy
and it is not going to it it it causes
fires almost like elon's Teslas does it
again the parallels are [ __ ]
incredible here
but because because there's this
underlying tone
of climate change in there that's what
he's [ __ ] butt hurt about and of
course of course that the I'm sure the
the cast is a bunch of wokers and he
doesn't like that [ __ ] either
I fundamentally doesn't understand even
what movies are let me show you the
comments that he actually wrote on
Twitter here about this movie now he he
watched it I guess because he's writing
about it he says um then this is
yesterday
he says I regret to inform you which I'm
like what the f you regret to so he was
wanting it to be good I guess is what he
was saying I don't know I regret to him
for me Glass Onion is actively bad which
I don't know what actively bad means for
a movie but I will discuss first the
actual writing of the movie followed by
the politics of it see again there is no
avert politics in this movie
Texas ball I mean again there's this
underlining Thread about climate change
and energy because the guy the
billionaire is creating a product to
solve that issue so he thinks there's
politics in it right
he says both suck spoilers follow so he
doesn't give a [ __ ] that he spoils it
either which I really don't care if I
spoil mover for someone if you haven't
watched it it's your [ __ ] fault but
here's the thing he continues to say now
Texas fault this is a murder mystery
since you haven't seen knives out that's
a murdery murder mystery as well yeah I
got the gist of what they are I just
there's a murderer and they and and the
people like um the game the board game
Clue they're trying to solve the murder
and it's um a mystery it's why they call
it a murder mystery it's really not
complicated for Ben to understand here
but apparently maybe so I mean he
doesn't understand how to get his wife's
[ __ ] wet what makes us think that he
wouldn't understand what a murder
mystery is so he goes on to stay here
first the writing which I thought the
writing was great objectively but then
he says the first half of the movie is
is a complete misdirect and a waste of
time and he clearly does not understand
he doesn't understand the women's bodies
and how to you know make them horny and
his wife in particular he said it on a
show but apparently he does not know
what a murder mystery movie is either I
know right he's bitching about a plot
twist one thing I want to say we are
harsh but we are not mean so that thing
you keep saying about how he doesn't
know how to get his wife wet Publix you
know just for disclosure Ben Shapiro
says I mean he said that himself about
himself I mean so no we're not being
[ __ ] mean there we're just feeling
sorry people saying we're being mean in
the comments because if they are no I I
just I just want to be clear about that
I want a disclosure you wanna
himself and by the way he hate he hates
the song [ __ ] which is [ __ ] ironic
because there is a laid out set of
instructions how to make that happen
right there in the song man I mean it's
just maybe that's why he hates it I
don't know I don't know I don't know but
anyway literally doesn't understand the
music and he clearly doesn't understand
movies he just does yeah a murder
mystery with a plot twist wow you know I
mean oh that's terrible I mean
we're able to watch that [ __ ] movie
how dare they want people
uh you can see it we can't see it
but uh yeah how dare they want to want
to get people to watch that movie by
making sure there's a plot twist and a
murder mystery are you [ __ ] kidding
me that's his major [ __ ] about this
thing is that there's a major plot twist
or some [ __ ] now people were pointing
out Texas Paul this is [ __ ] I did not
know
I did not know that Ben Shapiro is a
failed screenwriter this is hilarious
now I
I knew about the gun show do you know
about the the Ben Shapiro gun show
no I don't that I don't know about but I
knew he was an attempted screenwriter oh
well he's an attempted um
um heartthrob too so I apparently when
he goes on his Tick-Tock lives and his
Instagram lives they they want him to do
a gun show so he he rolls up his sleeves
and he he he flexes his biceps and he
does these
[Music]
he actually well I'll show you some
videos we'll get to the the and his
biceps are are that big that big I mean
he is it works out probably but I mean
what the hell does that have to do I
mean it is Ben Shapiro so you know
anyone thinking that that you've got to
keep it in scale man I mean the guy is
like elf on a shelf I mean he's not a
big guy you know I mean
and I'm not body shaming him or anything
except for the fact that he wears lifts
like that freaking tall
you know it's like I laugh because
people say Paul you're fat and I'm like
well no [ __ ] [ __ ] I spent a lot of
money to get this way God damn you know
but oh Ben Shapiro is trying to pretend
he ain't like a mini me you know I don't
get it damn they're all like that here's
here's an interview I don't know when
this is from but
um he's talking about his failed
screenwriting in this and it's [ __ ]
fantastic
um I thought the gun show was completely
embarrassing and really anything Ben
Shapiro says on film is embarrassing but
this is like chef's kiss let's listen
well let me say I've yet to know of too
many conservatives which is where you
put yourself who are funny I mean it has
to do with a humor that is transferable
to you to Everyday living
ah so she Burns him in this clip she
Burns him into first breath takes his
fall and it's true have you watched this
uh what's the [ __ ] the guy on Fox News
that he thinks he's a comedian they have
a show they think it's [ __ ] hilarious
uh gut field that's what it is great gut
field and they think they're hilarious
which if you're laughing at
non-objectively funny humor you're a
dumb [ __ ] you're a dumb [ __ ] and that's
what she's trying to tell him here and
he absolutely he absolutely is not
listening to her line of questioning
because listen to his response it's
hilarious I mean I I utterly disagree
with that I think there there can be
conservatives who are funny liberals may
not find them funny all right I mean
okay Ann Coulter for conservatives is
funny okay no she's not no she literally
he literally just said Ann Coulter is
funny that that that and then I mean
that's funny Texas well that's funny
that he thinks Ann Coulter is funny
that's hilarious see that's the thing
go ahead Tim Allen Tim Allen's funny he
is funny but he's not as funny as he
used to be when he when he had told time
he was freaking hilarious a lot of
self-deprecating humor in there the guy
had a sense of humor then he made some
money and ended up get moving farther
and farther right on the scale and just
became bitter and pissed off and in his
last show I can't even watch it man it's
just it's just constant bitching and
moaning continues that's not humor folks
that's not humor no make a little fun of
yourself lighten up a little bit you
know these conservatives
[ __ ] butt hurt ain't funny you know
see and that's the thing is there's a
couple different types of humor right
and good humor is like he says
self-deprecating you're making fun of
yourself and a lot of the the tool time
or home improvement with Tim Allen was
him either either hurting himself kind
of like a Three Stooges type thing or he
was making fun of himself now the other
type of humor is punching punching up
right you're you're what's George Carlin
um some of the greats Eddie Murphy uh uh
uh Richard Pryor so well
um they did so well punching up right
and even Dave Chappelle at a point in
his career punched up a lot
but the punching down humor just is not
objectively funny because that's not
really in human interactions it's not
typically what people find humorous is
when you punch down because that's what
conservatives do that's what Dave
Chappelle has continued to make part of
his act where he's punching down I think
that's what you're saying about Tim
Allen where he used to be
self-deprecating now he's using the
punching down technique of humor which
is not objectively funny
um but yeah but it goes on he goes on to
talk about Bill Martin and Ann Coulter
here a little bit let's listen okay for
liberals she's not funny Bill Maher for
liberals hilarious for conservatives not
funny and there's well that depends
because you're using Politics as the uh
form of their humor but Bill Cosby is
relatively conservative today yeah and I
know even back then that's that's you
know the idea that conservatism is
inherently unfunny is not true it's the
conservatives have abandoned the playing
field of humor and narrative I'll agree
with you there I think that they've
totally run away from battle but that
doesn't mean that there's not the
capacity within conservative thoughts to
be funny
see this is this is the thing about the
yeah go ahead go ahead go ahead okay
public service announcement
don't claim Bill Cosby on your [ __ ]
side I don't care what you're doing I
don't care what you're doing
don't use Bill Cosby as an example of
your side okay I'm sorry
would you expect I would bet that Ben
Shapiro would say that same [ __ ] today
about Bill Cosby even knowing what he
knows actually frankly he would probably
lean into it a bit he's like ah that
Bill Cosby guy well you know he was just
having fun just just having conservative
old fun you know that's how it works do
one thing or say one thing and do
another you know this guy
this this this [ __ ] guy
when you think about it
with the success that he's had on the
right this makes sense
why why he's had such a success with
white trumped up right-wing Nazis why
he's had so much success with him
because they are so entrenched in their
own obsession with how they can be
oppressed to make sure that they can
steal away
steal away the grievance of other folks
and here he is stealing away the
grievance of humor because he failed as
a screenwriter it only makes sense that
that that these people just follow him
around like sheep
I mean I have a few people that I know
personally that I don't even talk too
much anymore and the one reason why is
because every other [ __ ] political
opinion they had his name would come out
of their mouth and I'm like you are such
a [ __ ] cuck I'm like when do you ever
just form an opinion on your own he's
like well well that's the reason why I
formed my opinion on my own is because I
listen to [ __ ] I do my research and
this [ __ ] I'm like look the guy the guy
does is is not that as smart as he
[ __ ] thinks he is and what he's doing
is a mind trick on you to convince you
that he's smart so anything any
shit-eating thing he says out of his
mouth you think is in intelligent stuff
here are the guys trying to break down
humor and he's not even doing a good job
of it it really is and I'm the and the
main reason why it takes balls because
he doesn't know what humor is uh and I
need to correct him on one thing Bill
Maher's not [ __ ] funny I mean he he
was I followed him I used to love the
guy I watched him all the way back to
politically correct and and used to
follow the guy for years but now he's
just [ __ ] fat phobic or right wing
sucker and and and and
bitter old guy yelling get off my
[ __ ] lawn man it's not funny anymore
you want to know why Bill Maher doesn't
seem funny anymore do you want to know
why Bill Maher does not need an audience
anymore Bill Maher does not need money
anymore Bill not Bill Maher does not
need Fame anymore he doesn't need any of
that at one point in his life he did
need it now Bill Martin was always
pretty much a straight talker I used to
watch Politically Incorrect when I was
young that's what I cut my teeth on
politics some of my favorite episodes
are George Carlin and Larry Flint
on Bill Maher pissing off conservatives
about porno and cuss words [ __ ]
hilarious great content some of the best
content ever made in on network
television believe it or not now Bill
Martin lost
um his show politically incorrect
because of his statements about 9 11
right after 9 11 and then he went to HBO
and now he has real time
um Bill Maher is funny he's a comedian
he is funny his jokes are funny
when he makes when he when he makes sure
that he is not punching down when Bill
Maher is punching up to Power Bill Maher
is [ __ ] funny but when Bill Maher
punches down it is not funny objectively
humor that punches down when you are
using jokes to punch down at people it
is not funny
you're not trying and you should not
claim that it's jokes you should not
claim that it's humor it is [ __ ]
garbage and that's why conservatives are
mad that no one finds them funny because
they continue to punch down at every
measure rather they're using humor or
they're actually serious about it and
that's the problem that's the problem
with them punching down and trying to do
the humor thing is because the bio [ __ ]
that that they'll say out of their
mouths when they're punching down they
actually believe it almost every real
comedian and then I don't know if
conservatives out there listening to me
almost every real comedian that is
telling a joke is exaggerating you
[ __ ] morons they're exaggerating
their actual personal beliefs it's an
exaggeration that's the whole point of
the joke but you know most people don't
know that let's finish up here with Ben
shapir because I want to show you the
gun show I can't I can't not show you
the gun show let's listen to this you
talk about having conceived of the plot
for a TV series and worked with Lenny
Goldberg
was that a comedy was it sitcom was it
drama it's more of a dramedy he was
based on Harvard Law School as a dramedy
I've written a couple comedies uh kind
of hour-long dramedies for uh you know
spec script and have they been bought uh
no because no and then there are a
couple reasons for that one is that it's
hard to sell anything in this town yeah
thank you period you know regardless of
political Viewpoint
um and uh the other is that you know and
especially a breakout Series right right
from the get-go right I mean it's hard
to tell a spec script you start as a
baby writer I mean you know the process
yeah have you worked continually with
Lena Goldberg since uh yeah I worked
with him for several months afterward
and then he got sidetracked with unknown
and with uh Blue Bloods on CBS and and
all of that you know like everything
else in Hollywood things go into
development and then they kind of get
sidetracked they go sideways for a while
so well uh poor Ben Shapiro he wasn't
able to capitalize on his elitism in
Hollywood so what he did was he turned
he turned to right wing talk radio
because he couldn't capitalize on his
elitism because that's truly what he's
pissed off about here Texas ball and
ain't got nothing to do with political
opinions and he is mad because he didn't
get to capitalize on his elitism which
he is an elite he went to Harvard he's
writing [ __ ] screenplays about
Harvard Jesus Christ
and you know I'll be honest with you
it's really not hard to sell something
in Hollywood if you've got an original
idea they are desperate for new ideas in
Hollywood you could sell if you wrote If
you I'm telling you people if you've if
you've got an original idea
don't do what I do where you write [ __ ]
and delete it write [ __ ] and delete it
write [ __ ] and delete it keep that [ __ ]
keep writing Hollywood needs you right
now Ben Shapiro just has nothing [ __ ]
original the guy is the only reason we
are saying his name is the is the right
wing [ __ ] system for creating these
guys they took a guy they told everybody
in the world he was super [ __ ] smart
he's super [ __ ] smart super [ __ ]
smart and then all he does is he takes
the biased
[ __ ] that is in right Winger's Minds he
says it back to them and then calls them
Geniuses for thinking like quote he
thinks and that's that's the entire
[ __ ] stick with Ben Shapiro just take
the bias the hate the the idiocy the the
the you know just just the crazy that's
in the right wing say it back to them
like it's your idea and then tell
everybody that just heard you how smart
they are for thinking the way you think
when really all you did was just engage
in confirmation bias I mean that's it
that's the whole [ __ ] thing and it
fortunately it's running out of gas it's
really running out of people are getting
really sick of it we're living through
history right now you know I'm old
enough to remember when everything about
a quarter Century goes swung right to
Republicans
because of the freaking narrative and
this well all of that has finally tanked
out and run out of gas and everything is
swinging back to the left we just need
to not [ __ ] it up that's right we need
to keep going after them
um
speaking of confirmation bias
this is why he does this [ __ ] gun
show on his lives because
apparently there are people who like to
see him do this so because he's got two
people that like to see him do this and
confirm that they like to see him do
this he's got confirmation bias that
this gun show thing is [ __ ] cool
you're not gonna you're not gonna
believe this watch this here we go
dude there's no Cuts in there
foreign
literally is a thing that he does now I
don't
um the mods are gonna hate me for saying
this probably because um the chat will
light up and today we don't we as
everyone noticed we don't have Gabe
Sanchez with him with us he took a an
extra game he took it if you're watching
I miss you
he misses you and I think I think the
mods again are going to kill me for this
but I think we should actually
um every Tuesday when we do get Gabe
back on here we should make it a
tradition Texas Paul and maybe you can
remind me of this that we should have a
shirt off no no I mean you can if you
want to I'm talking about Gabe Sanchez
we'll have Gabe Sanchez do the gun show
I'm sure the audience will love that I'm
just saying yeah the moderators because
the the chat's gonna light up it's gonna
be like
a pinball you know what this just hit me
man and and tell me if it's out of line
here because Gabe ain't here okay yeah
well but let's compare Gabe to Ben
Shapiro
yeah let me tell you Gabe is genuinely
one smart [ __ ] right he is
gifted he is extremely gifted he is
funny he is talented he is going to go a
long [ __ ] ways he really is you know
then and the guy
is small in stature you know what I mean
but he doesn't [ __ ] wear [ __ ]
lifts that tall he doesn't he's not like
a little pitch depending depending on
the video on what wig he's wearing he
might wear high heels I'm just saying
I'm sure Gabe's got a pair of high heels
to go with a couple of those wigs you
know but you know it would be for a bit
it's not his his self the guys got
confidence self the guys humor yeah
exactly yeah I mean he's he is he's a
great guy and I'm not just kissing his
ass because he does a show with us I'm
telling you working with the guy I've
worked with people that were total
[ __ ] I have uh you know what I mean
but but Gabe is not that man he is a
good guy he is and smart as [ __ ] man I
mean the guy guy has forgotten things
that I wish I'd ever I'd learned in the
first place
but compare that to [ __ ] [ __ ] over
here Ben Shapiro I mean he's he's got
confidence issues he's got problems
nobody around him will tell him to pluck
his [ __ ] eyebrows I mean he looks
like he's got two [ __ ] Billow brillo
pads taped to his forehead
probably does manicure his eyebrows I'm
I'm almost bet on it I mean it has no
shame about it no I mean I have to trim
mine because if I don't I get that
they're they're everywhere I have to I
have to shave my goddamn ears and so how
much hair I got coming out of my you
know trim the nose trim the you know I
mean look young but I'm getting old
um here is one comment woohoo Gabe guns
so maybe maybe um maybe the audience can
remind us again that the mods are going
to be mad at me we have the best
moderators in the world but they're
going to be mad at me over this probably
because this will light up the chat next
time Gabe's here
um see Gabe is a stud they love Gabe
they love him in the chat now we've done
the um
funny yeah well absolutely and and the
audience loves the Gabe guns because
we've done the Ben Shapiro thing he's
played it before because he thinks it's
hilarious which it is and there's
actually better videos of Ben Shapiro
doing the gun show than this one where
he's like grunting and [ __ ] can you
imagine that's probably why his wife
doesn't get [ __ ] is because he's like can
you imagine him standing at the end of
the bed going
does that do it for you baby
oh
my God okay never been Shapiro
um Texas ball
I really I gotta get your opinion on
this because I know you're gonna do
probably several videos on this but what
do you expect out of these Trump taxes
um because they're gonna start to drop
now we had the report and we know a lot
about what is going to come but we don't
actually we won't actually see
um the returns and more than anything
the analysis of the returns because to
be honest with you I don't I [ __ ]
don't know [ __ ] about tax returns when I
have my accountant do it and they send
it to me it's it's almost like a foreign
language to me anyways I give them all
the numbers I give them all the [ __ ] and
then it comes back and you know it's
something different than what I even
know but so tax returns
you got to be a smart [ __ ] to
know a lot of tax policy and about tax
policy and really how to snip out crimes
of tax policy but I don't think that's
what he's concerned about Donald Trump
the Cheeto dust cue in honor the grandpa
Poopypants he's not concerned about the
crime he thinks he's going to get away
with it the crime that is
um what do you think is going to happen
to these tax returns of course he's
going to freak the [ __ ] out uh on true
social if he hasn't already let me check
why you're why you're giving this your
your yeah what we're going to find out
is is what we've suspected I mean he's
not donating his salary we're going to
find out that he's didn't donate his
salary we're going to find out that he's
actually just worth a few million
dollars
um that you know his equity and his
Properties or [ __ ]
um we're gonna find out that Hunter
Biden has more net worth than the
[ __ ] entire Trump business that's a
hell that's what we're going to find out
well hey Rosemont Seneca is actually a
successful investment firm I mean they
they they I mean his his Hunter Biden's
stake in Rosemont Seneca I will wager is
worth more than Trump Inc
oh I that probably is true
um because I actually don't think that
Hunter Biden's an idiot he's he's no he
loves drugs and he loves hookers I mean
rather you like it or hate it you know
what what are you gonna do I mean you
know because he's got a lot of problems
have you ever dealt with anybody with an
addiction
have I I've had addictions it does not
make sense does it I mean it doesn't
have to make sense
it just doesn't make sense you got a guy
that's smart like Hunter [ __ ] Biden
who can sit there at a table and
negotiate his ass off his his biggest
deal was that he could he could take
people that were in shitty situations of
their own creation people like Ukraine
the Ukraine businesses like like barisma
that wanted to transform from an old
Soviet company to a new modern Western
company but they had
burn Bridges because they were an old
Soviet company
he could con as a consultant could get
these people into Western Finance he
could get these people to reinvent
themselves to to put the safeguards in
place and everything so they would be
accepted that's what he did for a living
because he's a smart [ __ ] he is
but Trump trump is no smart [ __ ]
this guy is
we're gonna find out that he is worth
less than what he inherited that's what
we're gonna find oh absolutely which is
which is pathetic because it's it's
upwards to a half a billion dollars is
what he inherited from his dad and he
stole from his brother now um in the
inheritance him and his sister both
stole that [ __ ] money
um here here's which is you know typical
for them here's the thing about Hunter
Biden too
is a lot of people don't know the
history
of what actually happened to Joe Biden
and his two sons now right before Jill
Biden became a senator of Delaware his
family was in a car accident
killing his wife his daughter and his
two sons survived
as to survive they were in yeah Hunter
Biden sat in that car and watched his
mom and sister die right and
um he had to grow up
as a United States senator's son in the
public eye under this storyline okay
because it was right before Joe Biden I
think swore in at the hospital near him
his son's bid uh bo and Hunter's bed now
Beau Biden
um was in the military he was very
successful he was very successful in
politics and he he probably had a really
bright future in politics and we all
know he got he got cancer and passed
away
um which is even more tragic on his
brother Hunter I'm sure
but
in that right because I'm not I'm Not
Gonna Knock anybody for liking hooker
and hookers and blow you know whatever
you want to do with your life really is
fine by me as long as you're not hurting
other people I mean you know you rent a
hotel room you get some drugs which I
don't think really should be that much
of a crime these days and you want to
have sex whatever you want to do right
I'm not going to shame you for that sort
of thing because I don't think anything
other than you know your moral opinion
about drugs or sex is what Hunter Biden
offends because really honestly at the
end of the day this whole thing about
the laptop boils down to they don't get
to see pictures of his huge [ __ ] on the
internet which is [ __ ] infuriating
because the fact is is that Hunter Biden
did try to skate on taxes he did try to
do that and the IRS has already worked
out a plan to make sure that he [ __ ]
he pays what he owes in taxes which I
actually do not believe that we should
be putting people
including Hunter Biden or anyone else
who didn't do their taxes just right and
the IRS doesn't like it in [ __ ]
prison we should make them pay the
[ __ ] amount that they owe and the
penalties or whatever move on with it
Jesus Christ we're going to lock up
every single [ __ ] person again no
because I I I I I don't think Donald
Trump Jr should go to jail for [ __ ]
loving blow in hotel rooms with hookers
I don't and I know Donald Trump Jr has
definitely I mean I'm just thinking here
almost definitely probably more than
likely has been in a hotel room with a
[ __ ] whole line lines of coke and and
prostitutes for sure Stormy Daniels yeah
right one in well Junior Donald Trump
whatever the [ __ ] the point is is that
look
is Hunter Biden a little off the rails
yeah does Joe Biden know it [ __ ] yeah
why do you think the guy isn't his top
number one advisor just down the hall
does he love his son yeah that's why
Daniel Donald Trump Jr is pissed off is
because Joe Biden loves his son
unconditionally it doesn't matter what
Hunter Biden does or doesn't do he loves
his [ __ ] son because Joe Biden is a
decent [ __ ] we just happened to
elect someone with that reached the bar
of decency in our White House which is
incredible that that's the [ __ ] bar
but that's where we're at I guess but
here's the thing uh also about
um Hunter Biden and the taxes and all
that
that is the reason why you're saying is
the is Donald Trump is going to be known
as a broke [ __ ] and that's what
I was trying to say in the first 30
minutes
is that maybe the narrative maybe you're
on to something here Texas Paul that if
we can make the narrative and the
national message that Hunter Biden is
worth more than Donald Trump oh my God
how [ __ ] sweet do you have any idea
how much I mean the Cheeto dust unit on
her head would would set on fire
if if the national narrative was that
Hunter Biden is worth more money than
Donald Trump holy [ __ ] that is brilliant
by the way
well it's just a fact I mean Rosemont
Seneca is an extremely and if you don't
know that
John Kerry's kid and and Hunter Biden
got together and started an investment
firm if you know their history it makes
perfect sense because Hunter Biden went
to school and actually got an education
yeah and went to Yale
yeah he got a job coming out out of
school for the world's largest bank at
the time it was MBNA worked his way up
to being an Executive Vice President
learned the business so he understands
Finance uh I mean this is what the guy
does didn't you know he was pointing to
the board of Amtrak he's he's you know
people were like well why did he end up
on marisma were you dumb [ __ ] because
that's what he does for a living his
Consulting business his his lobbying and
Consulting businesses were all geared
around helping companies that have
difficulties
assimilating into Western Society
assimilate into Western Society properly
and he makes money doing it he's been
successful his whole life his only
hiccup was with the fact that he has
dealt with addiction his whole damn life
and so is his sister
it is a problem I mean if you
when you have tragedies in your life
if you're already genetically
predisposed to addiction
man
yeah as somebody who's dealt with
somebody that's had Addiction in their
life
great people
can fall to addiction they can it
doesn't mean that they lose everything
that they were they're still great
people Hunter Biden's still a smart
successful [ __ ] he is and the
fact that he had an addiction
and ended up you know doing blow and and
you know all the [ __ ] that was going on
with you know he came up at a time when
everybody was doing [ __ ] blow
everybody was doing blow
I mean it was you know it was just
and to see him compare him to Don Jr as
you were doing earlier
what a [ __ ] joke man
bro it's really has done nothing with
his life but that's really the Revenge
of the Trump family on on us right is
that is that they're as much as is as
Elite as they want us to believe they
are they are not invited into the elite
Circle because they are a bunch of dumb
[ __ ]
there's no way no way that John Kerry's
kid would ever partner with Donald Trump
Jr because he's a [ __ ] idiot no way
that that any smart politicians kid who
became a success in business would
partner with Eric Trump their [ __ ]
buffoons they're just [ __ ] buffoons
and that's what pisses them off the most
is because they don't be get to be part
of the of the elite it's the same thing
when Donald Trump couldn't own an NFL
team so he went and bought a usfl team
same [ __ ] same old story
this is I I can I I advised people do
not hide from Hunter Biden lean into
Hunter right and and the Democratic
establishment would not [ __ ] listen
to me and they didn't do it so now you
the reason the Republicans went after
Hunter Biden isn't barisma it isn't any
of that because that could all be I mean
it's all factual it's all documents you
can look at it and say okay that didn't
happen you know I mean it's just it's
it's not something that's debatable the
reason they went after Hunter Biden was
his success in life
he was incredibly successful in life
of those doors he was an addict and
that's like
whereas Trump never was successful right
so they had to go after Hunter Biden in
the Democrats instead of us saying [ __ ]
yeah we love Hunter Biden because he's a
goddamn success and having something to
be proud of
we said okay well we won't we won't let
them burden us with Hunter Biden what
the [ __ ] do you think they were going to
stop going after Hunter Biden they're
you know they're still doing it today
they think they're going to hold
hearings on Hunter Biden which I cannot
wait for oh it's gonna be fantastic if
you
told me okay we're gonna have a debate
and we're gonna Bet On It
and we're going to have one side Jim
Jordan
the [ __ ] wrestling coach and on the
other side we're going to have Hunter
Biden who specializes in dealing with
some of the most powerful and some of
the most dangerous situations you can be
in I mean it was the Turning I don't
know if you're aware of the business
environment coming out of the Soviet
Union but it was at the point of a gun
usually well and it really is even
Ukraine is even as much as they're
trying to save their democracy it it is
that that democracy hangs by threads
because of corruption
um
he wants yeah zelinski has said he wants
to be a modern European country that's
right you know but you tell me Jim
Jordan versus Hunter Biden oh [ __ ]
I'll mortgage my house to bet on that
[ __ ] well that you know the
greatest part and if I hope Democrats do
this and really it needs to be us um
pushing the narrative and by us I mean
me and you but the audience specifically
that we need to push this narrative to
make sure the Democrats in that
committee prove prove without a shadow
of a doubt that what they're saying
about Hunter Biden is just not [ __ ]
true it's not true and the way that they
prove it's exactly what you're saying
like yeah he was a success so what
you're so you're jealous you're [ __ ]
jealous that he was a success and Donald
Trump Jr is a [ __ ] worthless piece of
[ __ ] is that what you're saying the day
I'm from Junior has to sell [ __ ]
t-shirts with his dad's name on him
whereas Hunter Biden actually is worth a
lot of [ __ ] money so much [ __ ]
money that he messed up on his taxes and
he owes a [ __ ] listen when you owe a
shitload of money and taxes you made a
shitload of money the reason why Donald
Trump only paid 750 bucks or no taxes at
all because he made no losing money
money [ __ ] boneheads it's not
complicated to understand and this idea
that he hid behind real estate all those
years I mean yeah you can hide behind
real estate and tax shelter a lot of
your income in real estate but let me
tell you something the extent of that
with a billionaire is is not going to be
this entire [ __ ] income and if it is
he's more of a bonehead than he wants to
believe
um speaking of um billionaires and
boneheads I don't mean to switch two two
seven years but I want to talk about um
Tesla and I want to talk about Elon and
this seems like a perfect a perfect
transition from stupid [ __ ]
billionaires that aren't worth the money
they say they're worth
um to talk about listen I actually never
believed at this point that Elon was the
richest man in the world think it was
all [ __ ] it was all just [ __ ]
numbers on a page
um the Forbes thing is all [ __ ] the
richest man in the world thing's all
[ __ ] um here uh William legate is
not much left before Elon gets
margin called and the stock goes into
death spiral Tesla investors are
scrambling to get out why they still can
this is about an hour ago and here's
Tesla I told you it's gonna drop below
100 maybe today I was thinking by when
or Wednesday or Thursday I'm still
thinking this Monday I guess
um by Wednesday or Thursday but here we
are it's it's just now below 112 which
is 72 now
um it's definitely gonna dip below uh
100 which is going to get at 80 percent
of value which
um I forget what it was pre-pandemic I
know it was below 100 but we're he's
gonna lose every single bit of value
that he gained during the pandemic and
the the craziest part is this stupid son
of a [ __ ] sold 30 billion dollars of
that stock driving it even lower and he
won't stop tweeting this is [ __ ]
crazy Texas Paul to watch a
billionaireself destruct like this
because this is not just Tesla that is
being destroyed it is elon's fake ass
reputation and the fraud that he's some
kind of smart [ __ ] because he's
Rich this is playing out just and we and
I honestly this is more reason why we
should tax the actual [ __ ] out of every
single billionaire but you know that's
just my opinion
yeah it's just you know man when when
when when Elon Musk took over Twitter
you know I said okay great I can cuss my
ass off fantastic I don't have a problem
with that and then he started saying a
stupid few stupid things and then he
started firing people I'm like okay that
can be fixed you can say look the
company's not making money we have to
fire people I mean there there were
there were points where where you could
return from when the [ __ ] twit files
came out it was over
[ __ ] over there was no redeeming this
[ __ ]
it was over and and I couldn't believe
you know I kept saying [ __ ] Elon Musk
call me call me I will go I'm not that
far from your gigafactory here in Austin
I will go sit down we're gonna sit on a
private link and I will give you some
[ __ ] advice that you can do so you
can turn this [ __ ] around and who did he
go to Barry [ __ ] Weiss
Barry Weiss the same [ __ ] person that
has [ __ ] up Bill Maher's head
you know Barry Weiss that's who you're
going to get to turn this [ __ ] around
she [ __ ] destroyed the New York Times
you know I mean the people that he
surrounds himself with are and that's
one thing you can say about Republicans
they can't govern but they can sweet
talk a billionaire man they could tell
him he's got the biggest dick in the
world that he is the smartest
[ __ ] in the world and and just
every you know and play to all they know
they know how to boot lick better than
any other [ __ ] that I've ever
seen these [ __ ] Republicans know how
to boot lick like a [ __ ] because
you got to remember Elon Musk is
supposedly The Godfather of the
electrical vehicle which is they're
adamantly opposed to EVS which is
insanity to me like we could sit here
and discuss this whole EB thing and
their ideology around it because they
hate [ __ ] solar panels and [ __ ] like
they like solar panels and windmills
haven't [ __ ] existed for decades and
decades and decades we're just now
investing in the technology to make sure
that we can we have energy and energy
Independence in this country so we can
debate that all day long but it is
absolutely [ __ ] back to me that they
are so ingrained in boot licking these
[ __ ] that they are willing to
Bootleg Elon Musk and he is willing to
destroy destroy one one of the key
[ __ ] companies that is driving the EV
market and has been and it I mean we
both know this we both know that GM and
Chevrolet and Honda Toyota these
companies are Dynamic lights are way too
big at Giants for Tesla to ever compete
once Chevrolet and GM are and Ford and
and Toyota and Honda once they catch up
once they catch up Tesla's done and I
mean they may build batteries but
they're not going to have cars Tesla
will not be in the car market and the
one reason why is because they've never
let Elon have dealerships in these
states they've always boxed them out
that's been his challenge the entire
time that's why Tesla can't get legs and
run it's worth a lot of [ __ ] money
well it was until he started talking and
started being Elon out in the open but
listen
Tesla is not going to sell cars forever
it'll be around
maybe but they're probably going to be
more entrenched in the in the in the um
in the actual battery and some of the
charging type technology because GM GM
and Ford and Toyota and taunt they are
not going to let this [ __ ] into
the market they're not that's been his
problem the entire time with Tesla folks
you know I I I don't know if you can see
my face is turning red I can feel it
getting hot I'm just I I got Tesla was
in a unique position when everybody said
we're not going to do electric cars Elon
Musk said watch me right and he did it
he [ __ ] did it I mean it was it was a
struggle and and they never really made
money on their cars very much it was all
about yeah he did it with our money Bud
yeah he did he did the money that he did
it with but you got to give him this he
kicked the [ __ ] door open had he
stayed doing what he was doing instead
of getting bored and [ __ ] running off
and letting his goddamn Asperger's take
[ __ ] control if he'd surrounded
himself with people there's a reason do
you know who Mary Barra is she's the CEO
of GM nobody knows her name right nobody
nobody knows her if you're not inside
politics Paul yeah yeah there is because
you can go to at mtbara is her Twitter
handle at mtbara and if you pull that up
and look at it
it's about [ __ ] cars and she doesn't
write these tweets there are Graphics
put together by by the her
Communications team and they put tweets
out
for GM it's almost like she runs a
really big corporation that relies on
getting Capital relies on banks relies
on uh employment relies on
infrastructure it seems like she's in
charge of a really big important
Corporation so much so that Obama even
saved that corporation's ass back
um 2008 or something I think there was
yeah everybody likes to pretend that a
corporation that's Run by One headstrong
individual is great it's not great it is
not it Howard Hughes was not great for
Hughes aircraft you know Hughes
schooling he was not I mean he almost
destroyed it because of yeah because of
his [ __ ] ideas that he couldn't
control himself and he didn't have
people around him that's what these
corporations do they built strong boards
that insist that their upper echelon
management be strong people that
understand how to do things and Tesla
had such a this is why my face just
burns when I see this had such a you
unique opportunity in this market if he
had been focusing on making the next
generation of Teslas nobody would have
been giving a [ __ ] if these cars were
catching on fire he could have just said
yeah well you know it was the first
generation and moved on and nobody would
have [ __ ] cared nobody would have
[ __ ] cared right he would have
settled out of court he'd settle that to
court and then moved on yeah yeah I mean
it's just and people would have given
him a pass
for all of this because they know you're
developing a new type of automobile a
modern electric vehicle okay great so
what did he do he sat on his ass and
waited till every major like you said
every major corporation you've got you
know the forward lightning you've got
the new GM coming out you've got
Volkswagen the you know are they still
the largest car manufacturer in the
world I believe they are I haven't
checked that statistic in a while the
largest car manufacturer in the world
are making luxury EVS through Audi
they're making you know you've got uh
their Mainline EVS are coming out
through the Volkswagen brand
they're going to bury [ __ ] Tesla for
the reason that you said they have the
machines that do it
and they know
how to keep from shooting themselves in
the damn foot
you know they do you know Volkswagen had
their problem with the Diesels that
where they were overestimating their
diesel mileage nobody remembers that
[ __ ] why because they're coming out with
a whole new generation of electric
vehicles
they didn't sit there and talk
themselves into a [ __ ] grave and that
was the part that just pisses me off
about Elon Musk is this was there are
people at that factory there are people
I'm just a few hours for me his
gigafactory I can I could be there today
standing in his parking lot
and I would see employees vehicles
all over the damn place they're going to
lose everything
those people are going to lose
everything because of Elon musk's
[ __ ] mouth
and I get it Elon Musk when he moved to
Texas
he was listening to the you know Greg
Abbott Dan Patrick Ken Paxton all these
[ __ ] donors around here that I can
you know billionaire donors are [ __ ]
human beings they really are and but
they sure know how to suck off a
billionaire and man
they got in his [ __ ] head they got in
his [ __ ] head
and now we have separated for sure yeah
and and you've got Elin running around
believing this [ __ ] another Kanye West
you know just just people got in Kanye
you had a billion dollar business but
started hanging around with the white
ring right-wing boot lickers and and and
believe in their [ __ ] and destroyed
himself because you know hey you know
who's the market for your cars people
that give a [ __ ] about the environment
excuse me are those liberals or
conservatives because last time I
checked it was the [ __ ] liberals that
were your goddamn customer base
maybe we shouldn't insult them maybe we
should but here's what I think Texas
Paul with with the competition because
that's the thing that he's running into
is he's going to have a lot of
competition
but the problem with this competition is
it's not going to be about [ __ ]
climate change if anyone on this planet
believes that GM and Ford are absolutely
concerned with climate change you are a
dumb [ __ ] GM and Ford and all
these other manufacturers corporations
are concerned about one [ __ ] thing
one thing
and it's what Texas Paul said earlier
it's their profitability and if you have
some dumb [ __ ] tweeting out a bunch of
crazy ass [ __ ] who's running your
company and driving into the ground they
would be kicking rocks very quickly
because it would affect their bottom
line I'm telling you I'm telling you
that that the Ford Lightning all these
EVS that are going to be put out by
these these major car manufacturers it's
not going to have a hella beans work to
do about climate change it will it
affect it maybe I don't know we'll we'll
work that out but the reason why is
because because Democrats and liberals
in this country have committed
themselves to build the infrastructure
to make sure that EVS are the future of
automobiles in this country we are an
automobile country to think that we are
going to have high speed rails all over
the country going everywhere is
ridiculous it's not going to happen in
the near future we are an automobile
country
and until we actually get the
infrastructure the Market's not going to
be there well the the infrastructure is
coming slowly but surely the
infrastructure is coming and I'm telling
you these major car manufacturers aren't
they don't give a [ __ ] about climate
change why do you think the Ford pickup
looks like a goddamn Ford pickup they're
not trying to appeal to to the lip [ __ ]
down the street they're trying to appeal
to people who buy pickup trucks they
want it to look like a pickup they want
it to feel like a pickup that's the
whole point that's the point why they're
gonna buy it so I actually believe that
Elon Musk has missed his point in
history
and how he's missed his point in history
is he really did lean into EVS but he
leaned in the wrong way because it was
all about him everything was about him
with Tesla and and when you do that when
you do that when you pin your entire
company on you and then you go out and
do [ __ ] like you do at Twitter
it destroys it destroys that company it
absolutely destroys it because no one
will ever be able to think Tesla without
thinking about what he has done to Tesla
Twitter and himself and his reputation
at this point in history in just a
matter of months he's destroyed that
he's some kind of Smart Genius he's a
billionaire I mean I didn't believe it
before I actually gave him way too much
credit I I mean I thought he was smart
enough not to do this no look man you
know me I I tell it straight I do I tell
it straight this guy
has one really good gift to him
he gets an ID in his head and he's like
a [ __ ] Bulldog on it to prove that he
can do it the problem is he got the idea
in his head about Twitter and it was a
[ __ ] up idea and nobody can turn his
head on that to the day he dies he will
think he was right about Twitter and
what he did at Twitter nobody will ever
be able to tell him that he was [ __ ]
wrong
he'll destroy all of his companies but
yeah that the guy the guy had the
ability to say okay I'm gonna [ __ ] do
this I'm I am going to make home solar a
thing
you know and and he dove into that and
where other other people were like well
we don't know we don't want to know if
we want to go that way or what's going
to happen England's like no I'm going to
make it happen
I'll give the guy that much I will give
him that much
but you have to have controls man you
have to have people around you that will
tell you the truth about you and
yourself and he had that at Tesla that's
one thing he had at Tesla he had really
smart people that knew the technology
that knew they could develop the
technology that we're very confident in
it could give him the confidence he does
not have that at Twitter so he is real
and raw you are seeing who Elon Musk is
when there are no guard rails you are
seeing who he is because when when he
was with Peter Thiel and they were doing
like PayPal and [ __ ] he had the guard
rails on then too he always has had the
guardrails on until now and that is why
it's like what the [ __ ] well elon's been
this dumb for a long time I mean we we
have uh Gabe Sanchez has some friends
that work at SpaceX that are actual
rocket science they are [ __ ] real
rocket scientists and they say they've
been in a room with Elon Musk talking
about SpaceX and he is a dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] he has no clue what
he's talking about he has not a goddamn
clue like you said he has money and he
has ambition that's what he has and that
is what makes him a billionaire and
really honestly that's why we should tax
the ever loving [ __ ] out of them if
they're not going to give it away
um I know Jeff Bezos uh you know a lot
of people don't like Jeff Bezos but Jeff
Bezos is taking the path of like Warren
Buffett and Bill Gates where he's
actually tapped Dolly Parton which I
think is a brilliant idea by the way I
think it's one of the best ideas Jeff
Bezos has ever [ __ ] had and he will
live out his legacy that that is the
best decision he has ever made in his
career is to let Dolly Parton give away
his money because she is brilliant at
giving away money and she's not really
giving away a lot of his money anyways
but it's just brilliant move well but
you know what but you get what I'm
saying about about because Jeff Bezos
knows that he can't continue without
giving away his fortune he's got to give
some part of it away way or he's gonna
end up like Elon he's just there are tax
benefits is doing but but you know Jeff
Bezos started in a garage he wasn't Elon
Musk Elon Musk was the the the
son of an emerald minor Out of Africa
man I mean he he was [ __ ] Rich when
he hit the United States Jeff Bezos
started in his garage he built a company
he got a little bit of a big head there
for a little while
immediately gut checked himself and shut
the [ __ ] up you don't hear out of Jeff
business you don't he's not running
around saying look at me look at me look
at me no he put competent people in
charge of Amazon and said run this
mother this Logistics nightmare run it
and they do you know you don't have Jeff
Bezos sitting at [ __ ] Amazon saying I
want you to do this I want you to do
this no he'd say you know I got an idea
and they'll say huh
yeah that won't work and he says oh okay
well I'll think of another idea he
doesn't tweet that much either
no no actually one of his last tweets
was from November 12th here's the video
uh where he's letting Dolly Parton I'm
gonna mute it um this is the video where
he's he's he's he's he's basically
giving uh Dolly partner on an award but
he's also tapping her uh to try to give
away part of his fortune because most
the time
and and Warren Buffett's talked about
this several times Texas Paul that
people who are really good at making
money are really horrible at giving it
away they're just [ __ ] horrible at it
it's one reason why uh Warren Buffett
tapped Bill and uh Melinda Gates to give
away his fortune is because they're
really good at giving it away mainly her
probably not so much him but her but but
they're really good at giving it away so
that's why Warren Buffett is smart
enough to know if you're gonna give away
a fortune you might as well what someone
who's gonna do the most good that they
can possibly do with every single dollar
and that's why they tap Bill and Melinda
Gates
um to do that and and they've done it
they've done a ton of good all around
the world which pays dividends to us as
human beings okay and it pays dividends
to us as a society not just here but all
around the world to the money that
Warren Buffett earned through capitalism
and then knowing good enough to know
that you you should give that [ __ ] away
and you should do it in a specific way
that benefits as many human beings as
possible well and there's bound to be
people here that don't know why we're
raving about Dolly Parton so much you
know I'm not a religious guy I'm not but
Dolly Parton if I if you said had to
tell me name somebody that's a Christian
a real Christian right I would say Dolly
Parton she
folks don't know that she's been giving
her she's and not just giving her money
away to give it away
she's been you know things that's close
to her things that are close to her
heart uh bands and and and uh choirs and
church choirs and school choirs and
every she she all around the country she
pays for these uniforms for these people
very quietly you don't know it
she doesn't advertise it she takes all
of the money that she makes out of
Dollywood and go to Dollywood it's a
great place she is not she's like old
Texas boss just because we're Southern
Hillbillies doesn't mean that you know
we're bad people we're not she's she's
one of the good ones man she is a good
person she is a down-to-earth Christian
she came from poor she made a lot of
money and she helped people around her
every way she could and she she's just a
wonderful human being she really is she
doesn't get into politics that much
because she just doesn't like the
infighting and [ __ ] like that she's just
like hey be good to people and we'll all
be okay
you know I mean she's a wonderful human
being and Jeff Bezos could you're right
Tony you are absolutely right he could
not have picked
anyone better than Dolly Parton and her
team to head up his Charities he just
couldn't
well and and she's given so much to her
home state to her community members
after tornadoes after storms after
floods
um she's just she's just one of the best
human beings that has been given the
power that she's been given because
Dolly Parton has the power to entertain
more than anything
um that she has not just not just with
her music she does these uh Story Time
reads that she did during the pandemic
and she's just so goddamn entertaining
and even way back when when women
weren't given the right to own their own
material and their own content she said
no that's my [ __ ] that's my those are
that's my content I'm gonna [ __ ] own
it and she made a fortune off of it
because she's such a good Entertainer a
[ __ ] fortune and more than anything
it's because Dolly Parton is real she's
authentic I mean she wears the wigs and
the makeup and the costumes but that is
who she is that's her that is Dolly
Parton and I believe because she's so
authentic that is why she is such a
great human being because she doesn't
need to be anybody else but herself and
it's um and I think I think Jeff Bezos
seeing this and recognizing that there's
no better person to give away his
fortune and honestly I think like you
said earlier he gave way less than he
should have to Dolly to to divvy up
um but I think her and her team will do
an excellent job at giving away whatever
Fortune he's willing to let her give
away because she is an extra human being
I'm actually trying to look for a clip
and while we're talking of Dolly but I'm
not finding the one I want go ahead and
if I could throw one more thing out
there about Jake Bezos because you know
a lot of people like to give him grief
because he's like well the working
conditions in in his warehouses and and
the wages could be higher and this and
the other you're not arguing with Jeff
Bezos on that you aren't Jeff Bezos has
stepped away from that company a long
time ago it has it it has a president it
has a you know peop managers that are
running that kind that's who you're
arguing with you're not arguing with
Jeff Bezos it's like saying trying to
argue with Bill Gates because you're
pissed off at windows 11. it's stupid he
hasn't done anything in Microsoft since
the 90s I mean you know it's just
know who you're arguing with and what
you're arguing about instead of trying
to cancel somebody like well I think you
should cancel Bill Gates because it was
[ __ ] Epstein [ __ ] but don't [ __ ]
kids okay it's not that hard don't [ __ ]
kids don't [ __ ] around on your wife
that's a good one too that that's a real
good one too but yeah when you [ __ ]
around on your wife don't [ __ ] a kid
so yeah I'm not a real fan of Bill Gates
but
just remember who you're arguing with
you know everybody wants to say hell
Jeff Bezos is a bad guy because of his
you know the warehouses and this and the
other you know
he owns the stock that that's what he
does for a living his own your fight is
with the managers on the labor yeah and
they're winning they're by the way labor
is winning because the American people
during the pandemic got wise to labor
and what they're trading away for so
long in this country and I said this a
thousand times and I'll say it a
thousand times more I'm sure is that
most people don't know
that their number one piece of capital
that they're that they have is there is
their time and their labor and they're
trading their labor for a wage and
they're trading their labor for benefits
and we discovered that during the
pandemic that we should not be thanking
these corporations for the job they
should be thanking us for our labor and
there was no time during the pandemic
and more clear than that and really
still were people like oh we can't get
any help can't find any good help that's
because you're [ __ ] your [ __ ] maybe you
as a company should look Inward and see
why no one wants to [ __ ] trade their
labor for your money um I want to go
this is a clip this isn't the one I'm
looking for but
um this is one of Dolly Parton getting
inducted in the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame here's here's a clip
I figure if I'm gonna be in the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame
I'm gonna have to earn it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up Rock
I grew up loving Elvis and Wildman Jerry
Lee took very little Richard they all
cast a spell on me Carl Perkins and
those loose red shoes had no place on
the farm but there's better than them
broke hands I was wearing around the
barn with my transistors
Smoky Hill Tennessee Tennessee
I still got rock and roll down
thank you Dolly Parton um for blessing
us with your talent all this time what a
great way to go out of the show by the
way off Dolly Parton and I'm probably
gonna get hit with some kind of
copyright thing on YouTube but I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't care uh it's worth
it it's worth it with with Dolly Parton
it truly is it truly is and she she is
the best of us
um the the best of us and that is the
reason why is because that person you
just saw with all the the makeup and the
hair and the costume and the lights that
is really truly who she is that is her
that is authentic unlike some of these
other [ __ ] out there like
Republicans like George Santos which I
can't wait to talk about him more and
more and more in the coming months
Donald Trump as we're gonna watch to see
what kind of fraud he is with his tax
returns and Elon Musk how much he's been
how how long he's been hiding his
stupidity that's been the theme to have
a full circle Texas Paul I started with
Donald Trump's taxes Elon tanking Tesla
and George Santos and why and then we
also Ben Shapiro
um wouldn't know a good movie if it sat
on his face so I think we've come full
circle here today thanks for joining us
on Tuesday audience make sure to go
follow Texas Paul's YouTube channel
don't miss a single episode of Sunday
coffee with Texas Paul the link is down
below I put the link in there below
today so go to his YouTube channel give
him a subscribe over there make sure to
subscribe here at the Tony Michaels
podcast if you're on YouTube you're not
going to want to miss a single thing
bonehead of the week is back this week
Texas Paul so make sure to go follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you can
vote here on YouTube on the community
tab or vote on Twitter we will have the
bonehead of the week this Friday as we
do every single Friday well last one we
had to take a vacation but this Friday
it's back it's back also download every
single episode on Apple Spotify Google
don't forget to leave us a great review
why you're why you're subscribing to
your favorite directory to the Tony
Michaels podcast Texas Paul give us one
last word
Tony it's always a pleasure to be here
man I enjoy this more than anything I do
this is this is one of the highlights of
my week man I really do that that my
final word is about you
why Merry [ __ ] Christmas I love doing
this show with you man I really do I you
and Gabe just have have a great thing
going here and I just it's it's a real
pleasure and I enjoy the hell out of it
I really do well I couldn't do it
without him I couldn't do it on Tuesdays
without you and I definitely couldn't do
it out the moderators or the audience
the greatest audience in the world
everyone same time same place tomorrow
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the mind is touch
Facebook page until then Surf's Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow
toning on social media at the Tony
Michaels and until next time raise a
fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon